the goal for this video is to add a
debug UI for our game where we can print
any value or property to test it in real
time first we create a new scene that
will hold our debug UI nodes the scene
will contain a root control node a panel
container node and a vbox container node
as we add properties we'll create new
label control nodes procedurally as
children of our vbox container create a
new script and attach it to the parent
debug node I'm going to add this debug
scene to my main scene controller your
setup might be a bit different if you're
not following the tutorial series but
basically I want the debug scene to be
low on my scene tree so that it is
layered above other scenes in the tree
we're going to reference this tobg
script using our Global script autoload
doing this will allow us to access our
debug functions from anywhere in my
Global script I add a debug variable for
my debug class name in our debug script
we create that class name and the
following variables and constant a
properties array that will hold any
debug labels we create a reference to
our vbox container node I'm using the
onready reference technique but you can
also use an export variable reference
then a constant that will reference our
frame time in milliseconds I'm going to
explain why this is here in a minute but
basically like you can and unreal I want
to be able to set how often the debug
property updates there may be times
where you only want it to update every
second and not every frame in our ready
function we access our Global autoload
and set the debug variable reference ref
to self and set visible to false well
want a way to toggle our debug panel UI
off and on so we need to add an input
button I've added a debug event in the
input map with the Tilt key we use the
input function to check if the event
press is the debug event and if it is we
set visible to not visible this may look
a little odd but it's an easy way to
basically flip-flop our Boolean value
every time we press the debug key then
we need to add get viewport set input as
handled to count the input event as red
got's input system flows through an
input tree and our key input will get
read by other functions in that tree
further down if we don't tell the engine
that we considered it handled hence we
add this line then we create a new
function add debug property this
function is what we'll use to create new
debug properties in our UI and other
scripts we need a few parameters an ID
name the value we want to pass along and
a time in frames for how often we want
to update the value the L statement will
get run the first time the function is
called we create a new label node add
that label node as a child to our vbox
container set the name to our ID and the
label text to our ID plus our value
notice we're converting our value to a
string because labels require strings
and won't accept things like Floats or
integers then we add our new property ID
to our properties array so we can check
for it in the next frame in our if
statement we check our properties array
to see if it contains our previous prly
created ID name if it does we don't want
to create another label we want to
update the existing one so we set our
Target by finding the child of the
container that equals the ID name and
then we set our text value again with
our new updated value this is going to
update our dbook property value every
frame finally I added another if
statement here to check for our time and
Frames the idea is to set the number of
frames we want to update this value when
we run our function these functions will
be called in our phys phics process
functions and other scripts so they'll
be capped at 60 frames per second if we
use a value of one that means we'll
update this every one frame if we use 60
we'll update it every 60 frames or every
second to do this we check if the total
milliseconds elapsed divided by our FPS
Ms value which is 16 divided by our time
and Frames has a remainder of zero if it
does then we update our value it might
be a little crude but I did feel that it
was better than creating a bunch of
different timers that might run every
frame you should now be able to call
this function in any physics process
function to debug any property from any
script
[Music]